people don't understand that the world's
always evolving in 18 you live to 40.
rich life expecting so when I see people
that are 52 and 49 and 47 and there's
unhappiness you know they have that
moment whatever it is their 50th
birthday a bad day at work it could be
anything that triggers the [__] this is
it all those dreams I had it's over look
at me with age comes more worry your
kids older kids are bigger headaches
than little kids things start to happen
you lose a parent this is what happens
when you get to 30 40 50 60 but I'm like
yes comma you're 46 you'll probably live
another 46 years probably by the way and
what are you gonna do about it because I
promise if you start dwelling that it's
[__] up or over or not as good as I
wanted to be you're really making a huge
mistake because you have a lot of life
left